will smith now stepping out for the
first time since his oscar nomination to
celebrate his fresh prince twins bari
banks at the red carpet premiere for
ballet now this is a story all about how
my life i had vowed i would never ever
touch the fresh prince of bel-air hey
welcome to cali
i went from an absolute hell no to
oh my goodness this could be spectacular
spectacular is also the perfect word to
describe last night's epic red carpet
will was joined by wife jada and son
jayden and check out the og cast
including tatiana ali and joseph marcel
meeting bel air's next generation
let the music defuse jabari who plays
will sure understood the assignment when
tasked with this challenge you gotta do
the first print shake with him
[Music]
bel air which is a dramatic recreation
of the beloved 90s series premieres
sunday on peacock will just dropped a
new super bowl spot where he gives a
global twist to that iconic
of a town called theme
this is prime time this ain't cable
of course e.t has been on the set of the
fresh prince since day one this is the
first thing i've ever done acting you
know so i have zero formal theatrical
training jabari told our denny directo
bel-air is also his first role how
prepared are you to be famous
and i don't know if anyone's just
prepared adrian holmes and cassandra
freeman play uncle phil in aunt vivian
they said the whole cast is celebrating
will's king richard osternods i'm sure
we're gonna go to the oscars it only
makes sense oh yeah oh yeah i mean it
only makes sense for the whole cast
about her to be there you saw it here
first right here
[Music]
you